House of the Dragon has already had some
majorly [ __ ] up things happen in it
there's been deaths whilst giving birth
women asking dragons to kill them kids
with wild teeth and fighting pits and so
much more however there's an even worse
moment coming down the line that I
thought we'd talk about in this video
now either you've read the book and
already knew what it would be from the
thumbnail or you haven't and are just
curious by the tease with Helena either
way I will be spoiling one of the
upcoming chapters in the book so if you
don't want to know then I'll recommend
you head off like baymund please hit the
Thumbs Up Button if you enjoy the video
you're sick [ __ ] and make sure you
subscribe for more House of the Dragon
breakdowns with that out of the way huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the video okay so in order to
set the situation up we have to talk
about one of the major deaths that
happens early on in the dance of the
dragons useris and Eamon are both
dispatched to Storm's end in order to
try and get people on their side the
baratheons are a major house and having
them on board would have the potential
to swing the Civil War in their favor
aim and arrived there first and he
agreed to marry one of Lord boris's
daughters in order to strengthen both
sides Lucero showed up not long after
but as he was already betrayed to his
cousin he couldn't do the same thing
Eamonn demanded that he cut out his eye
and now Luke didn't do this Eamonn
eventually did get his revenge he
followed lucerus out and on the back of
vegar he killed him with his Dragon upon
learning this Damon promised renira that
there would be a son for his son and
this is where things really start to go
down Damon went to my zarya who as we've
seen has now Master foothold in the
Underworld of King's Landing she runs
almost all aspects of it outside of the
senior elements like the fighting pits
we saw in episode 9. Damon asks for her
to become his instrument in order to
inflict pain on the high towers and she
hires two assassins in Blood and cheese
according to the books one was a
sergeant in the city watch that had his
goal clerk removed for beating a
prostitute to death the other was a rat
catcher who had worked in the red keep
known as cheese for using well cheese he
had mastered all the ins and outs of the
keep whilst hunting after the Vermin
this meant that he had experienced
knowledge of all the back passages
hidden doorways and the secret tunnels
that could lead one to anywhere in the
castle devised by maegor the cruel these
could often be found when candles were
seen flickering due to a draft coming
from under a doorway the book tells us
they used a once forgotten passageway
and through this they went into the
heart of the keep they hadn't been told
who to kill only that there should be a
sun for a son after the death of viserys
Queen Alison had moved to residency in
the tower of the hand and this is where
they headed to they crept through the
passageways and popped up in Alison's
room which is where they gagged the
queen and strangled her bedmate yeah
they waited bully aware that Helena used
to bring the children in to see the
queen every night before they were put
to bed in the darkness they leapt out
and killed her Gods before cheese crab
mailor with a knife pointed to his neck
he start to lay out the terms after
introducing himself as a debt collector
in our breakdowns we've often talked
about how that was very much an eye for
an eye mentality that was started all
the way back in eamonn's childhood after
he lost his Alison demanded that Lucero
San over one too and this would be
carried into the character's death
several years later she's actually said
the line an eye for an eye a sun for a
son we only want the one to square
things won't let the rest of your fine
folks not one little Heir which one you
want to lose your grace horror then
crept over Helena's face as she realized
what he meant as most parents would she
offered her life in the place of her
children's but blood chillingly added a
wife's not a son it has to be a boy from
this point Elena was in an impossible
situation she had no chance of Escape I
would have to choose one of her children
to die if you've ever seen the film
savvy's Choice then you'll likely be
aware of the similar situation that's
presented in that it's a terrifying
Prospect for any parent with it meaning
life for one child but the guild and
grief of knowing that another died Elena
pleaded while she was on her knees for
them to stop but she said that if she
didn't choose soon that blood would
assault their little girl jihara with
time running short Helena made a choice
and she picked her youngest son mailor
in her mind he was too young to
understand what was going on and in her
heart she also carried the idea of
succession the oldest Sonja Harris was
aegon's first born and therefore he was
next in line for the throne cheese
whispered in Malaysia hear that little
boy your mama wants you dead according
to the source material cheese then
grinned at blood who instantly turned
and cut off to Harris's head instead in
one Bell swoop it had all been a ruse to
see which child she cared about the most
jaharis was killed then and there and
mail all would spend the rest of his
life knowing that his mother chose him
to die over his brother blood and cheese
actually kept their word and they didn't
harm Alison laneapp or any of the
children instead they snuck off through
the passages and fled into the night
carrying Jairus his head with them this
night of Terror would completely Change
Helena for the rest of her life and she
would end up eventually going insane the
book says that she wouldn't eat bathe
leave her Chambers and she couldn't look
at her surviving son malor she knew that
she chosen him to die and couldn't bring
herself to face up to what she'd done
eventually this got so bad that aegon
had the child taken away from her and he
was given over to Alison so that she
could raise him as her own it completely
rocked the Royals it was really when
rainer's side showed they weren't
messing around and would stoop to levels
of depravity in order to win this war
Helena was completely knocked out of the
fight and because of this the greens
lost a dragon on their side now due to
the level of the crime
Otto immediately had a search party sent
out for the two assassins blood was
seized trying to flee King's Landing
with to Harris's head and under torture
he confessed he was taking it to Damon
in harrenhal whilst he was being cut
apart he told them who'd given him the
job a woman named misery blood was
tortured for 13 days before before he
was eventually allowed to die and Alison
went to Laris and asked that he find out
his real name this is so that she could
have his entire family murdered but
whether this actually happened or not is
summing the book doesn't tell us the
king's God searched the streets of
King's Landing looking for both cheese
in Missouri but neither could be found
King Egg on demanded that all Iraq
hatches in the city were to be hanged
and after this was carried out a hundred
cats were brought in to try and hunt the
rats instead it's safe to say the family
were never the same again and it acts as
the last handful of paragraphs in the
sun first and chapter closing out what a
devastatingly brutal one I think at this
point the greens start to realize the
kind of war they'd brought on themselves
by robbing renera of her crown and son
up until this point they'd pretty much
been winning due to planting aegon and
taking out luceris however this showed
with an iPhone eye mentality that we
both lose our sight and it was all
studded by eamonn's need for Revenge
this was of course put in him by his
mother who tried to strike out one of
luceris's eyes when when they were
younger though she walked away from this
moment without getting into any trouble
would have major ramifications that
wouldn't be felt for decades Eamonn
would kill luceris eventually this would
lead to the death of joharis it start a
war of escalation in which both sides
try to constantly outdo the other
because they were worried about how bad
things might get this story is a perfect
exclamation of why the dance of the
Dragons was so costly and how it could
have all been avoided without the
poisoning and plotting that came from
the parents think when it finally makes
it to the show that this scene will be
Unforgettable and some yet sticks with
those who watch it for a long long time
now there are many many events in the
dance of the dragons that are completely
[ __ ] up and if you know another one
then make sure you comment below and let
me know and happier news we are in
competition right now and giving away
three copies of top gun Maverick on the
15th of November all you have to do to
be with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the video we
pick the comments out random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so that's
you then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch make sure you check out our
breakdown of why Eamonn is so important
I'll be linked on screen right now and
in it we talk about the character's
origin story what goes on happen with
him and lots of other things definitely
worth checking out so make sure you head
over there right after this by the way
thanks for sticking through the video
I've been poor I'll see you next time
take care peace